fire at a strip mall left five
businesses destroyed this all happened
just east of the strip and very early
this morning in fact this video here
behind me you can see these intense
flames that firefighters had to face
investigators on scene still at paradise
and flamingo trying to figure out what
started it hector mejia there reporting
live with the latest hector
we're told investigators have not been
able to conduct a thorough investigation
inside out of safety concerns in fact
this crew here wrapping up after putting
out a small flare up investigators tell
us they're still looking into the cause
but they believe the fire started in or
near the dry cleaners the owner mr steve
kim says that's been his business for
the last 30 years it's what kept him in
las vegas after he immigrated here from
south korea and it's one of several
businesses left destroyed this afternoon
crews are cleaning up after an intense
fire took out five strip mall businesses
at paradise and flamingo nathaniel
bridewell a loyal customer at royal
crest cleaners knows the owner i told
him i was really sorry about what
happened
and
so as he rebuilds i'm going to come
right back i go to this cleaner all the
time he's really good
as a matter of fact i just got something
out last week
you know but to see this
it's devastating recaptured video of the
flames the clark county fire department
shared footage of the thick smoke they
dealt with just after one this morning
people in the area saw the smoke and
dialed 9-1-1 it burned for quite some
time before anybody saw it once it gets
up into the attic space particularly
with a front fascia or mansur that we
have on these types of strip malls
those are very difficult to get into and
once
for firefighters and once fire gets in
there it can become a challenge to get
that fire to stop more than 50
firefighters responded and managed to
keep the flames from destroying the
entire strip mall saving a handful of
other businesses some are dealing with
water or smoke damage it's really hard
renting you know it seems like things
like this happen during the holidays
the landlord is here she did not want to
go on camera but she did share they're
just trying to figure out what's next as
they try to move forward reporting at
flamingo in paradise hector mejia live
local now